hey 42 here a lot of things that you
would naturally assume are against the
law aren't in many parts of the world
there are some really strange and often
disturbing things that you can legally
get away with first up is cannibalism
yes you heard that right
in most countries around the world
including the United States and most of
Europe there are no outright laws
against the consumption of human flesh
in most cases cannibals are charged with
murder however if someone willingly
gives you permission to Huck off a piece
of their flesh and eat it you're
strangely not doing anything illegal
have you ever wanted to own a tiger well
you're in luck it's illegal to own a
tiger in the UK under the dangerous wild
animals Act but in Canada and several US
states it's completely fine in the eyes
of the law to go online and buy a tiger
then bring it home which is easier than
you may think in case you were wondering
a baby Bengal tiger will cost you around
one thousand dollars in fourteen US
states it's legal to own a tiger however
you are required to register for a
permit to own large cats however in nine
states there are no laws against it
whatsoever you can just go ahead and buy
one despite the significant risks that
they can pose to the public in fact
there are currently 12,000 privately
owned pet Tigers in America and that
excludes the ones kept in zoos next up
is radar detectors these nifty little
boxes sit on your car's dashboard and
will alert you if your speed is being
monitored by the police using a radar
gun so that you can slow down it's
obvious to see why many people think
they're illegal since they allow you to
thwart the cop law enforcement methods
but surprisingly they're not they're
completely legal and most of Australia
some areas of Canada all of Russia
all of the United Kingdom and all of the
United States except from Washington DC
and Virginia however don't get radar
detectors mixed up with radar jammers
those are devices that jammed police
radar signals preventing them from
working full stop and these are very
much illegal using one will land you
with a one thousand dollar fine and one
year behind bars on the subject of
driving contrary to popular belief it's
completely legal to drive barefoot
that's right you can leave your shoes at
home and legally drive a car in most
countries including the United Kingdom
Canada and the US
although driving barefoot isn't as safe
as wearing shoes so a lot of traffic
enforcement officers will try to tell
you off for it anyway despite it being
legal we all know that breaking and
entering is illegal so you would be
forgiven if you thought that owning and
using lock picks is illegal too or turns
out it's 100% legal in most countries
it's completely legal to own and use
lock picks as long as you're not using
them to trespass on other people's
private property most countries however
do have a law against going equipped for
theft that means if a police officer
pulls you over at 3 a.m. and you have a
balaclava and a set of lock picks in
your car that qualifies is going equip
for fare and you're probably going down
the neck if that surprises you how about
this in America it's also legal to own a
flamethrower in most countries these
fossil fuel-burning weapons of
destruction are outright banned in the
UK for example you will receive 5 years
in prison if you're simply caught with a
flamethrower in your possession but in
the United States there is no federal
law against the possession and use of a
flamethrower regardless of how powerful
it is it's not just a deadly weapon
though in certain states in the south of
the United States and in some South
American
trees flamethrowers are used to fend off
deadly attacks on humans against
Africanized honeybees also known as
killer bees yes you can legally own a
flamethrower but that's not the only
deadly weapon you can legally own how
about a tank yes in most countries you
can legally own a tongue however don't
get too excited you can't go on grand
theft auto on innocent civilians the law
requires the tanks cannon to be
deactivated if you replaced a steel
tracked with rubber tracks and obtain a
certain permit you can also legally
drive your brand-new tank on the road
tanks are also surprisingly affordable
you can pick up an ex-soviet tank for
around $40,000 corporal punishment in
schools was outlawed in the United
Kingdom in 1987 and in Australia in 1985
however too many people surprised
corporal punishment is still completely
legal in nineteen states in America 19
states including Texas Alabama Florida
and Kentucky still allow a teacher or
principal to punish public school
students by hitting them repeatedly in
practice corporal punishment is becoming
increasingly less common in the United
States however a report in 2011 showed
that one texas school of ministered
corporal punishment to over 120
different kids in that year alone the
most common form of corporal punishment
in the u.s. is paddling where a student
is hit multiple times on their buttocks
or thighs with a wooden paddle however
in many such schools paddles are made
from shaved down baseball bats we've all
seen the films and TV shows where clever
criminals count cards during casino
blackjack games to cheat the house and
net large wins before being beat up and
thrown out by the casino security team
television therefore has made it quite
obvious that card counting is illegal or
is it well turns out it is
card counting is completely legal in the
majority of countries including the
United Kingdom and the United States
card counting is a blackjack technique
where players count the cards that I've
already been played to try and predict
what the dealer's next hand is likely to
be it's widely considered as cheating
and most casinos will actively try to
deter players from counting cards by
harassing players changing the
percentage of cards in the deck or using
extremely high speed dealers casinos are
completely within their rights to ban
you for this but it's certainly not
illegal and finally it's not just card
counting that films and TV has led us to
believe is against the law as a result
of it happening constantly on TV most
people believe that an undercover police
officer is required by law to identify
themselves when asked but it's simply
not true a police officer is legally
allowed to lie about their status and
basically anything else they like whilst
they are undercover they are even
allowed to fabricate facts and stories
to get information police do however
have to identify themselves to you if
they're in uniform or taking legal
action against you thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
you